[Music]
hey everybody happy tuesday and welcome
to another exciting episode of honest
trailer commentaries
it's been a while uh we we didn't do one
for uh the boys but i think we'll do a
nice makeup one at the end of the week
if you're
good yeah but i'm here with joe
long and danielle as always we are here
today to talk about
batman mask of the phantasm
uh which is a very evocative title for a
very evocative film
uh we're going to talk about our behind
the scenes thoughts uh show you the
trailer give our reactions to it watch
some cut jokes and then respond to
comments and questions from viewers like
you before teasing next week's honest
trailer
um i hadn't seen this movie uh until we
had to watch it
oh this is one of the better ones this
is a good one yeah it's really good
it's a good batman it's uh it's like
even though i
i saw it like when it was new but going
back it's remarkable how
serious it is throughout that there's no
effort to make it like
soften it for kids or make it more
family friendly it is like a noir movie
that just happens to be animated and
there's a bad guy in it
yeah yeah but likewise it's not uh
over-the-top
grim dark you know batman's not having
you know uh
drinking bruno and prison wine and you
know getting in shank fights or anything
like that like it's still
uh a kind of high arch gotham
style it's not uh it's not gritty and
grounded and real
it's emotionally real but it's not uh
there's no like
shock value stuff going on yeah no it's
just it's like a really grown up
dramatic story with like an emotional
through line that's really like about
the character of bruce wayne and batman
as opposed to just being like
get the penguin in there you know like
it's not you would think that the first
animated batman movie that wb did was
going to be just like crammed full of
villains and a lot of
fights and set pieces and it's really
not it's like more
kind of realistic and somber than a lot
of the live action
it is remarkable that a studio without
the power of hindsight years like i
could see a studio
like 10 years after batman the animated
series being like you know what people
sure love that thing
let's let paul dini like just kind of do
whatever for a movie
it's remarkable that without the power
of hindsight and nostalgia they were
still like what do you want to do
pauldini
and an emotionally driven
graveyard bottle episode feature length
batman okay like go for it
yeah it's it's uh uh i know this word is
somewhat meaningless but it's very
cinematic it's a
uh it arcs it's got uh like
this story of lost love and longing and
uh
it's it's like an epic tale with a with
a batman in it
so yeah this is one of my favorite
batman movies now uh yeah i gotta say
yeah for sure we're so lucky that that
dc and warner brothers brought in
pauldini and bruce tim at this pivotal
moment when they were kicking off all of
these animated
dc comics projects like the two best
people you could possibly have in the
room
like make stuff like this work yeah
i guess so yeah um danielle thoughts
oh yeah this is so we my batman scale i
have the same as i do my other movie
skills except it's like a micro because
it's batman where it's
i like movies because they are genuine
genuinely good and they go in a
different category and then i like
movies because i like them
um so of the batman movies that i like
you know
like in the scale of these are genuinely
good ones this is probably my second
favorite batman movie right under
returns um i would say um right under
returns
um and then followed by dark knight um
i really really really really love this
one and then of course
uh obviously batman and robin is my
favorite batman movie of things that are
bad
that is a different that's a different
scale they're different scales you have
to
yeah this suspect movie though like i i
think that
i think you can make a really solid
fight for this one being like
you know top three top five i feel like
all the movies try to crack
like who is bruce wayne and this one did
it really well and
really kind of easily at least they made
it feel very effortless to be like oh
this is who bruce wayne is and this is
why he's interesting
yeah um i think lon you brought this up
that i didn't realize that in this
universe he's
entirely self-taught like at everything
like this is a year two story i think i
think this is actually
sort of semi-based on a comic that's
like year two so i guess
maybe we could fill in like there was
time
he's remembering being pretty young and
like just starting out as batman
and there's no like league of shadows
here training him he's not like on a
mountain with the blue flower
like learning the crane kick like he
taught himself to be the world's
greatest detective
scientist and martial artist jiu jitsu
master yeah can learn a lot
that's a good that's his 20s were really
productive
look you can learn a ton with youtube
you guys like i've learned that in
quarantine
like i can't get a handyman over here
there's no social distancing so
something breaks you know i gotta do a
youtube video on how to switch out a
pipe
you know or learn jujitsu i find like
for all the problems of nolan i i'm not
you know i i don't think everything's
perfect about nolan's trilogy but he
does do a good job in batman begins of
kind of setting up like
here's how a guy who's just like a
random rich kid could learn how to be
sort of like a batman
and i like that i i didn't mean it as
criticism but basketball phantasm just
no he just he just figured it out one
day and it was just like
i'm going to be batman enough karate in
the front lawn
you know you start reading that four
hour day and you really figure out how
many things you can get done every day
batman's uh yeah they got the wayne
fortune is built off like a shady drop
shipping website that he that he runs
from uh
from puerto rico it's a multi-level
marketing scheme the
family you become uh you know batman and
then you have several bat family members
underneath you
is all essential oil sales it's
targeting midwestern housewives
gotham lady perfume and then yeah if you
if you unlock
wayne elite plus membership then they
throw you a party at the enormous uh
haberdashery skyscraper
let's see here and he teaches you
jiu-jitsu
his arc nemesis like is like the nexium
dude like the other guy running the big
mlm scheme in town yeah i see where this
got i like it all right let's watch the
honest trailer for uh batman
m.o the pee
[Music]
from the character who will be rebooted
every few years until all movies are
batman
comes the feature-length version of the
cartoon that babysat an entire
generation of latchkey nerds
thank you bad daddy
[Music]
um i i made sure that uh kevin pulled
that clip from
the worst episode about the animated
series that's the penguin one right
where the kids beat up the penguin with
the kids eat the [ __ ] out of the penguin
it's so good and it's like the fourth
episode of the show
so they were they were finding their
footing um but that that was the one
where they like you know they've got a
studio note of like kids need to see
kids on screen doing kid stuff
how about there's like a kid that uh you
know uh fights the penguin um
okay you sure you want less menacing i
mean he's one of the show's key villains
could we really reduce him to nothing
right away
what if the kids steal the batmobile
when batman's knocked unconscious
pauldini's like do you want this kid to
be robin no just out
the sound quite quite the opposite
actually more of like a peabody and
sherman type
yeah nemesis
no no wait they're gonna do that in the
movie someday
uh all right let's keep going t nerds
thank you bad daddy
batman mask of the phantasm
you've seen the story of how batman
began
a lot okay once more for good measure
okay that's enough i said enough
now strap in to learn the cost that
breaking bat took on bruce's soul
i i just want to do a quick uh either
show of hands or
or a bet uh do you guys think that we
will see a wayne's death scene in the
batman
in matt reeves the batman we're at least
gonna see pearls even if we don't see
we have to we're gonna see pearls even
if it's just like he looks at a pearl
and he's like
his mascara runs you know if you think
about it just
writing these stories you always need
that beat that's the stakes that's
why he's doing it you kind of have to at
some point at least tip your
cowl to the character's motivation
and it's you know crime alley dead
parent so i don't think we'll
necessarily get the full
like slo-mo zack snyder see every moment
play out in real time thing but yeah
yeah he'll at least have a flash to it
or will i get a nod to it or something
i'm with danielle we'll see pearls and
then you'll get a single mascara tear
wow yeah i i i think that it's become
enough of a trope that they're gonna
flip it and it's gonna be batman
shooting joe chill
a young bruce wayne can he accidentally
his parents are friendly fire yeah the
gun just keeps bouncing around
like uh true lies when jamie lee drops
the uzi down the stairs
i thought maybe joker we wouldn't have
to do it and then no he still had it
yeah all right well i'm not that i'm
laughing too much i'm sorry
you guys uh you guys have the pearls i'm
taking the opposite so we'll we'll see
we'll reconvene once
what i'd love is for someone to finally
meta examine how
that wouldn't happen to a real pearl
necklace if you ripped it off somebody's
uh
neck if you guys ever read that
apparently authentic pearl necklaces are
knotted in such a way that the pearls
wouldn't fly off if you broke the chain
are you saying that thomas brain's
cheap i'm just saying like like that is
like that's like the v
i think you became a billionaire joe
it's like that visual
inherited the pearl's going everywhere
reality would not be
that's the moment can you imagine the
moment that you die is the moment you
find out your pearls are fake
also how does how does bruce wayne have
the pearls later as a keepsake if they
went with some cop going through the
alley
you swept him up oh this kid's going to
want these one day as a sad remembrance
of this moment
say if he dedicates himself to
vigilantism i better
put all these things out that's a
commissioner gordon move right there
i just like that he's holding thomas's
hand and thomas is like don't be afraid
bruce and then he's holding martha's
hand and she's like this shit's from the
dollar general
are you a billionaire
okay i can't wait till we get our batman
movie uh all right let's keep going
i'll strap in to learn the craps that
breaking bat took on bruce's soul
because this cartoon is less about
gadgets and beat-em-ups and more about
the scars of a man
who took on an impossible burden i
didn't count on being happy
how much of this movie takes place in a
graveyard most of it
fun enter the scene
that line encapsulates like how crazy it
is that pauldini just got to make this
movie
just bruce wayne for kids on his knees
in front of a grave crying in a storm
saying i didn't count on being happy
that's incredible well it's like we've
explored a lot like how
difficult it is to be batman and like
the sacrifices like
every batman series sort of jumps into
that at some point but we've never
actually had to be like he hates being
bad like he wishes he didn't have to be
batman like yeah that's like taking it
to the next level
that i think not every batman like
that's when the studio exec
is like smash cut to the kids that
fought penguin like this is getting to
be too much
they're enjoying themselves i just
assumed that the uh
the repeated graveyard stuff was a cost
saving thing but no those are different
graveyard
uh backdrops at different times of day
uh they didn't just reuse the same
graveyard scene
no they had a lot of graveyard looks
yeah
there was a whole graveyard vision board
oh yeah the graveyard district over
there
the 30 graveyard so there's a lot of
options
okay keep going enter the seedy
underbelly of gotham
where the skyscrapers are tall and the
world's fairs go
ham to suit up with the batman
a collection of rectangles and feelings
as he takes on a new baddie the phantasm
i think they never actually say it out
loud they're a grim reaper with a power
of atmospheric farts
[Music]
who use us should we have
should we have was it necessary no no
was it necessary
no should we have definitely
the way he timed it out was what put it
over the top that was you joe right the
power of atmospheric farts i remember
that making me laugh in an email
yeah but then it was the execution that
really sold it for me
it's the little ones after the big ones
that's right
yeah at the end yeah yeah
i took less anxiety from that and more
anxiety from writing
uh i think that's his name they never
really say it because then
i've the rest of this week i've had an
ulcer being like they don't say it right
they don't say fantastic they don't
say i hope they don't say it nothing the
commenters would love more
than to jump on a a goof like that yeah
a little bit no i don't think they ever
actually do i mean
the phantasm certainly doesn't say it
they know that what's up with that claw
i feel like they
they're like in the middle of regrowing
half of that claw
well we were talking before about bruce
wayne self-taught so
andrea beaumont also self-taught like
how did she figure all this out
she made this skull mask yeah she's on
all these ocean liners they have classes
she studied metal shop in high school i
feel like the claw is is her hand in
there like this and that's just a thumb
claw
bring the claw back up that's close no i
think she's just holding onto it from
the inside and it's just a multi-purpose
the top one is for like
opening bottles yeah it's a can
opener slash deathclaw it's so close to
a pincher
like just just go full crab and just
give her the
crab to articulation batman mask of the
crab
would have worked just as well i am
crustacea
crustacean and he like always walks
sideways it'd be great
[Laughter]
crustacean sounds like a he-man villain
crustacean
yeah uh and that looks like skeleton all
right let's keep going
[Music]
who uses their martial arts and crab
claw to take out some of the oldest
fattest mobsters in gotham
thrill as batman rekindles an old flame
and andrea beaumont
another classic entry in bruce's we are
too damaged to make it work dating
history
even though they both share a love for
jiu jitsu and dead parents who are you
talking to
my mother what would a batman be without
a joker
unprofitable so mark hamill shows up
halfway through this one
watch his tank fall somewhere between
heath ledger's chaotic intensity
caesar romero's gentlemanly warning
before he tries to blow you up
i'm sending you a fun gift
in five minutes everything goes up
you're not batman after all
and jared leto's possibility that he
would be banging a robotic made for fun
you getting the moon company shows up
come on you really think they do the
first animated batman movie with an
original villain
i i like this uh uh take on the joker in
this movie because
i don't think he has like henchmen in
this one really so you really get the
sense that he's just hanging out
alone in this world in this abandoned
worlds fair like and he's just talking
to
uh his sex robot that's that's his only
companion
uh he has like a real like you buy the
insanity of a cartoon joker more than uh
more than some of the live-action ones
yeah i mean i think it's freeing to not
have to have him be like cool like they
want to make the joker cool now
and it's like no he's not there's
nothing cool about him he's just a crazy
psychopath
something cool about the joker kids yeah
like david leto like that's just so the
wrong approach because like no he's not
supposed to be like
cool like he's not hanging out in like
nightclubs being a badass
like ooh that's the joker like that that
doesn't make it and and joker having
henchmen has always been a thing that
never made any sense to me there is no
possibility that you were getting paid
enough to deal with
joker stuff like the failed stand-up
comic yeah oh god oh god
just improv all day he's just always on
ugh
i've got a new bit to try out but it's
also like that's how he expresses being
the joker is like shooting random people
unexpectedly like that's cause i'm the
joker like so you don't want to be
right there you're gonna get taken out
soon enough there's an end of the week
bonus for the best yes and
yeah if you're like a desirable goon
there's so many options you have in
gotham city
joker's got to be last on everyone's
list but is it like the prestige like do
they
he's like they get shots it's like super
villain david brent like you don't want
to be in an office with him all day
like no but then he's just going to be
like behind closed doors flipping a coin
like much easier
same time go ahead reads no just saying
like if you work for naomi campbell and
you get a phone thrown at you
you knew what you were getting into so
if you work for the joker and then
all of a sudden like you're surrounded
by joker fish and you can't stop smiling
and you don't know why
like you did that to you no one did that
to you again there's no way he pays that
much he pays an all
post jokered fish yeah but i think we
can't agree that
the gig economy in gotham is broken
the goon economy the good economy
well it's like a west world season three
there's that like app for
for crime that's what gotham needs is
like the penguins running a scam we need
eight bird themed henchmen yeah gooner
yeah you have your goon profile up there
i wrote this i wrote
i wrote this once uh i wrote a script
for this i called it hencher
henshire yeah not bad there you go yeah
i got it i mean like birds of prey could
have had that
and it wouldn't have been out of place
like if that element was in that movie
you'd be like i buy this
like a goon career fair yeah just like
each villain has their booth
it's also like the harley quinn show i
think kind of plays around with the
adventure brothers almost where it's
like that's a that's a viable job in
this universe
yeah you can work for the monarch you
know all right p venture brothers
all right let's keep going
the moon company shows up come on you
really think they'd do the first
animated batman movie with an original
villain we live in an infinite universe
with an infinite capacity for more joker
stuff
so return to the art deco nightmare of
pauldini's gotham
for an animated classic that deserves to
be at the top of your best bad list
by proving the best way to make batman
for adult audiences
isn't with violence even though the
bloodiness is pretty sick
or by porking bad girl for no good
reason although this batman
definitely falls but by pulling off what
creators have been trying to do
since the beginning make a cool noir
story about a guy who dresses like a bat
that reflects on how sad it is that he
can't stop doing so much awesome
punching
it's just so very
sad
[Music]
story the bachelor
phantom fanta don't you want a fanta
fandom you ever dance with the devil at
the abandoned world's fair
lord business r.i.p a pagoda
fast and the furious six or was it seven
when they did that
maybe five zim's mom
seven seven eight leave it seven no it
wasn't eight
it wasn't eight
yeah they steal like the super car from
the top of the tower yeah i think and
then they do it again
that's the one with ronda rousey in it
yes that's the party where she's the
bodyguard
is where they steal the car exactly yeah
i'm gonna stick with seven but i
wouldn't bet my life on it it's six
i'm pretty sure that is that is seven it
is six or seven but i'm pretty sure
you be the judge all right let's keep
going zim's mom
put a sock in the door bruce
[Music]
the ending of hot fuzz and bats wins
great timing with the music batman
forever
alone
geez mr saul i can't tell the difference
it's identical donna ben franklin
stubble
huh this seems like the kind of thing
the fbi could probably handle rather
than you know a violent vigilante didn't
realize batman even had a white-collar
crime division
yeah that shocked me at the very
beginning
he busts up a counterfeiting meeting and
beats the crap
out of everybody like that case is
ruined any kind of criminal case you
bring against them is ruined
like it seems like kind of an unspoken
rule like batman
violent crime like not not white talk
i'm not victimless
like violent crime you're not needed
here
i mean i think he would do more good for
gotham if he focused on white-collar
crime and just beat the crap out of like
people using tax shelters and stuff like
just like you said like it's sort of
like
misaligned like then you you ruin you
know you need you need investigators on
that or
like accountants and stuff we're gonna
be putting together not just like a guy
who's gonna punch everybody
yeah we had a paper trail but uh half of
them flew out this broken window they're
especially
yeah like they were done like just like
muggings that's but the
muggings are batman's bread and butter i
would say identity theft i think you'd
be pretty good at that right
yeah have they ever done a thing with
batman where like they do like point
break
where uh the guy's like i've been do you
think i like being undercover for a
month
my wife makes me sleep on the couch
because i smell and then your boys come
in here and start shooting the place up
like have they done that with batman
where he's like ha ha all that punching
and then some dude's like
dude i'm i'm seeing the case yeah i
don't think he's ever
like bullock's never been like you're
off the case
batman that would be funny that would be
so good though if like uh the last guy's
about to beat up he like pulls off the
guy's hat and it's bullock and he's like
dude
you wrecked this whole thing and we
didn't vetted for four months what are
you doing
i did like three surfing competitions
yeah and then that guy becomes a villain
yeah called undercover well first he he
screams and pounds the ground and fires
his gun into the air a bunch of times
yeah
i'd watch it um all right well that was
fun i think there's some stuff
that uh there's a good amount of stuff
we cut out so let's roll them
deleted scenes thrill
as batman rekindles an old flame and
andrea beaumont
and by rekindle i mean he's full-blown
stalking her
[Music]
sure it's for the case big guy we all
know that the computer does all your
detective work anyway
some kind of dense macromolecular
polymer adaptogenic of course
of course story is that a leroy jenkins
line
what well that sounded like leroy
jenkins repeating of course
wasn't leroy jenkins just leeroy jenkins
they had the whole back and forth before
the guy runs in where the dude is like
okay you're going to go over here we're
going to get this
you're repeating of course oh it could
be from from wow for sure yeah
yeah uh sorry it's been 18 years since i
watched the full libra jenkins
think about it every day bruce wayne is
animated typing like
it's like his fingers are moving like so
supernaturally fast
against these like huge keys yeah i love
a good
uh cartoon keyboard yeah always unmarked
keys
enormous light up thing he types like
400 words a minute
like again self-trained well actually
that's the thing is that nobody in film
or television uses a mouse
it's just not cinematic no one's ever
clicking
everyone's always both both hands up
here yeah
[Laughter]
well when you're when you're hacking
spencer yeah yeah you don't use the
mouse
naturally yeah actually um yeah
penny and her computer book was my
favorite from inspector gadget
i think i want to say elliott and mr
robot i believe has used a mouse
i want to throw i'm just going to put
that out now he's a hacker no way
i think i've seen him you've seen him
with at least a touch pad he uses
interactive vr gloves
real hackers dance
[Laughter]
uh all right what else we got and a
dense macromolecular polymer
adaptogenic of course of course
starring bruce mann little orphan
batmanny
the one that got them away jessica habit
vicky fail shredder smoke itching your
eye holes
darkwing dark hammel
killer clowns with acid face arthur
wreck
diarrhea batman begins returns
bruce almighty fantasia
i know what bruce did last summer
you knew this movie was going to be
awesome from the opening credits because
they brought in a choir to do the theme
music
if there's a choir the movie is fire i
learned that in film school
there you go jokes it's really good but
we have trouble using because we'd have
to play you a little bit of the song
and we don't have the rights yeah we're
terrified of playing music now
apparently youtube's
killer robots are highly trained when it
comes to using
score and so on but i know like people
in the comments sometimes be like why
did we talk about like this music this
needle drop
this score thing yes
yeah yeah that was especially with bebop
everyone was like why didn't you talk
about the soundtrack and it's like it's
great we literally can't we
like we could have sung our own version
but
yeah yeah it's a bummer but um just
imagine the songs in your head they're
very good
uh so let's respond to some of what
you guys are saying guys and gals uh
elias writes for lon
um batman did train with ninjas in the
cartoon i think and jason todd follows
up
he trained with ninjas and a master
illusionist in the series but there
wasn't time to get all that in the movie
right if this is yes like that kind of
points during the show i know they flash
back and it's got
i'm just saying like uh in the movie
it really is like it's like it's showing
you his preparation to be batman
and it's all just like him at his
mansion literally by himself
yeah but yeah sure there's and there is
like a league of shadows in the show
like roswell
gets in there eventually yeah uh
langley uh m neely what's up langley
writes it's one of if not the best
batman films of all time this and
spider-verse are examples of how
animation gives us the definitive
versions of these characters
you know strong statement but i kind of
i tend to agree i think that it's
uh especially since they started on the
page um
this is a way for them to kind of bridge
the gap between live action and
and comic books and where they're not
constrained by
reality and budget and stuff like that
but it still could make a deeper
connection than for some than a comic
so i agree with that i think animated uh
movies do
have kind of the ideal the platonic
ideal versions of batman and spider-man
in them
i mean i i agree but it's also an
interesting comparison because spider
versus using animation to like
do stuff that you really couldn't even
do in live action like it's like mixed
media
almost whereas this movie you could make
this movie in live action like there's
nothing particular to animation about
what they do here
it's just it's just interesting and it's
like a good it's like a well-told story
is what it
matters here i think i think the reason
why
animation got away with it in this case
is less about like
the the pushing the boundaries and more
that probably warner brothers was like
meh low stakes i don't feel like giving
them notes
and so they just got to make a great
movie under the radars right whereas if
you were gonna make
fantastic in live action they'd be like
it needs way more action
maybe the riddler can be in it too yeah
pearls
more girls yeah um
adam hallbert writes do you think the
batman reboot will be the closest to
noir in a live-action film
uh also uh prayers up for pattinson
recovering from his fight with covet
uh yeah from what i've seen
it doesn't look really noir-ish it looks
more like uh
i don't know seven like a fincher movie
or something like that
uh but i don't know what what has been
the most noirish batman yet i don't
i don't it's not much competition i mean
i think it's the animated series
hey the enemy's heroes are that 89 the
89 movie has a lot of like old-time
gangster
sort of elements with like the palance
nicholson stuff at the top
and you know like i think that's that's
sort of deeper than we've gone into the
into those kinds of stories than
certainly like the nolan
schumacher later [ __ ] later stuff
yeah all
and then right gonna be a detective like
if it is a detective story like they've
sort of promised then yeah it might have
some
nuari kind of elements but the trailer
does not yeah the trailer is much more
like fincher
yeah uh and finally john bainbridge
writes kevin conroy is forever the best
batman and the best bruce wayne agree
uh i mean i ain't gonna argue
yeah yeah uh it's he's
it's such a strong definitive
voice and take and um i
i i think what really kind of cements it
for the lead is that he was able to do
it over such a sustained amount of time
um and so i i think that really
that really hits it you know like i you
know billy my
kool-aid man through my window and and
be like val kilmer but val kilmer only
got to do it once valkyrie was a great
bruce wayne but he only got to do it he
only got you know one
one shot behind the batmobile wheel uh
whereas uh yeah conroy
got to really uh uh shoot his shot with
his character
hmm yeah i mean i'll cosign that
yeah i mean i i i'm split between i love
conroy's take and i totally agree with
what joe said like the
the longevity the range is super
impressive
i do like i feel like michael keaton's
the only one who's
really kind of tapped into the insanity
of bruce wayne like
not not a sane rational guy
making reasonable decisions and i think
michael keaton really brings that to the
surface whereas a lot of other people
play bruce wayne is like
basically he can just like become a
normal like a rich guy like hey how's it
going welcome to my party and like i
like that
i like that keaton's always like there's
a little bit of something off about him
even when he's trying to be
i like some manic energy for sure you
know they get that that
come on let's get nuts it's always like
right under the surface like it never
goes away completely
but i like the choice that this movie
makes where no he's not crazy he's
miserable i just can't stop punching
low-level criminals it's this weird
fetish i have um
all right well thank you guys for
joining us and thank you for watching
the honest trailer and this
and just watch batman master phantasm
it's short and it's really good
um again thank you for watching please
subscribe if you haven't already
and hit the like and the bell so you can
see this every time we do it which is
every tuesday
sju and other videos throughout the week
uh we're gonna do one for the boys
i believe on friday yeah um so don't
worry
didn't forget about them boys uh and
uh joe is there a special something you
want to plug
oh yeah uh uh we wanted to give some
love to
uh i think today and maybe this week for
just for like all of our
co-workers and peers and like
everybody's launching channels and
starting new ventures and um
we really want to make sure that you
guys are uh checking them out and giving
them some love i know uh
our our our lovely uh uh hug friend
scott mance
the master of movie dates and solid
handshake scott mance
launched his channel today so make sure
you check that out uh and you know make
sure you're watching uh you know our own
roxy striaer's doing live at the roxy
every day
uh everybody's busting ass right now and
and working really hard ken knapsocks
doing great stuff over on patreon
you know john rocca's doing the daily
show like all the all these folks are
really working hard and so make sure you
you check some check a new person out
today
yeah mr dan merle going strong give
everybody some love uh
some shares some comments a little goes
a long way
well there you go um like and subscribe
to all those things
and join us next week where we will be
doing something
brave and epic
and honest what are we doing making a
big brave choice it's very brave of us
yes very brave so brave uh
all right we'll see you next week i'll
tell you joe later
we did braveheart already
[Music]
you